[Music]
okay so this is my review
of wanda vision episode five on a very
special episode
now what's incredible about this episode
is it's another
incredible episode following last week's
great episode and the momentum just
keeps going here but what
really really stands out to me and works
in this episode
is that it finally hits a great
balance between what's going on outside
of west view and what's going on
inside of west view meaning we're seeing
sitcom
scenes blended with those scenes in real
time
with monica rambo and sword but what
also
really worked well is it beautifully
hit a midpoint here thematically that's
actually
shown when we see wanda say to the twins
we can't rush age in life because it's
convenient
and we can't reverse death just because
how sad it makes us
so what i mean by being that midpoint
thematically is that
writing wise they're having that line
written because it's the point where
our main character in wanda actually
says out loud which she's gonna have to
realize herself
and i think it's telling us what she
will eventually accomplish by the
end of this show is when she's gonna
understand this theme she's telling to
her twins
and process it and what this episode did
really well is it complicated things
even more
because last episode painting wanda as
the antagonist now we're really seeing
wanda's not the antagonist but she has
all these powers
and they're being controlled by
something else clearly and what's great
is they have this character of tyler
hayward being the complete opposite of a
monika rambo where monica
sees this side of wanda now also
being a victim in the situation where
tyler's just this bonehead
that is just looking at a black and
white that he calls her a terrorist
but monica's a really good protagonist
because she's not just this
by the numbers hero trying to just take
down whatever she sees as a threat
she sees more into the situation and i
think there's also
some political commentary here where the
scene they send a drone in and tyler
says to shoot at wanda it's just showing
you
how someone who's not a trained
professional in something like this can
really screw things up and make things
worse where monica was going with the
professional approach by talking
through to wanda and that shows here
when wanda actually comes out of west
view
confronts sword and monica's like i know
deep down you see me
as an ally i'm trying to help you and
she's right and wanda
sees that deep down and that's why she
obviously points the guns at tyler
hayward who is the idiot here but you're
getting a lot of answers here with
having new mystery and
those answers clearly are like monica's
lines saying i don't believe this was an
act of premeditated aggression
talking about wanda and that by the end
of the episode before we get this big
reveal of
you know who which you'll get to when
that doorbell rings
wanda's like that wasn't me and she has
a line i don't know how any of this
started in the first place division
and vision right now has his doubts
about how much wanda really knows and
how much she's actually causing all of
this
which is gonna have to be made through
from monica to vision at some point
because they're setting up right now
this
inner conflict between vision and wanda
he's trying to help her but he's not
fully believing her here that
she's a true victim here but that's
what's so interesting is they're going
to have the person she's grieving in
vision help her
work through her grief of him which is
really cool concept and just isn't a
tribute to how good this writing is
i absolutely loved in this scene when
vision confronts her
that the world of this sitcom still
trying to fighting to get through
through wanda with the
credits still playing it was so great
having those two forces go against each
other and they move the plot forward
really well this episode of vision
really now
figuring this out and what's actually
going on so it's just gonna really push
things into overdrive
but having these mysteries still coming
in like what's the bigger
source here of controlling wanda and her
powers
and this mystery of why are there no
other children besides these twins so i
really love to hear you guys theories on
that down below
and like i've said the attention to
detail is incredible by everyone on this
team working on the show from production
design
the writing the music amazing 80s theme
they think of here all the
theme music for each era they're hitting
is just awesome and hysterical and
elizabeth wilson really needs to be
considered for an emmy here already
because
she's pulling off something i don't know
how many people could actually pull off
in this type of role from
jumping into this brainwashed self doing
these different errors perfectly
hitting all the beats and then playing
like we saw here the real wanda we get
she's doing the accent again she's
really angry so
it's just a range of emotions she has to
hit and she's killing it but that's also
hit on now
is what wanda has to correct about
herself for her character to grow by the
end of this is because she's trying to
make the decision
for vision not to face what's outside of
westview like she says and he's like you
can't make that choice for me and paul
bettany has a
really great moment to shine here when
he sang the line
i can't remember my life before westview
i'm scared
really good there's so much horror
playing into the show which i love
and it's creepy that comes in that line
but it also comes in this scene
when vision's at work and he's figuring
it all out and everyone's kind of
bugging out
and they get the message from darcy
lewis that was just crazy
but that's what's so cool is you get so
many different types of genre playing in
this show
and with these big effective emotional
moments with vision and wanda in
particular in this episode
that only comes through being show
format which i think is so exciting
because the mcu is such a great track
record but for them to actually now do
this
in show formats just going to be able to
hit bigger emotional beats in the movies
ever could and we're already seeing that
and now remember what feeds into this
belief that something else is
controlling wanda's powers is that
she says to the twins in the middle of
this episode how her brother's far away
and she has a brother and then of course
by the end
the brother appears so something's
listening and making this happen so
it's huge we see pietro because one
it's evan peters playing him who played
him in the fox versions and now that mcu
has the rights to the mutants this is
huge
and it's addressed because darcy lewis
says the lion wow she recast her brother
in the sitcom so we don't know
if they're gonna keep it as evan peters
if they keep this quick silver thing
going
or if it's just for the version we see
in the sitcom world but it's huge
because the first time we're seeing
a fox character version in the mcu
and it makes you so excited x-men
x-men's my favorite marvel content so
i've dreamed of mcu taking care of it
and doing it
and this definitely's got to be the show
that's going to lead us towards
something mutant and it makes you
excited to see what other
fox actors are going to come over to
play their characters in the mcu but
it's just exciting as you know now
mutants are coming in
and there was also this hint of
fantastic four
in this episode when monica talks about
an aerospace engineer
could that be mr fantastic himself of
the fantastic four
that's also really exciting and just a
gold humorous line here to end the
episode with evan peters saying who's
the popsicle looking at vision that was
great so this is a brilliant episode i'm
giving it a 9.7
i would say just equally as great as
last week they're both just spectacular
and
it's just so exciting each week waiting
for one division to come out
comparing it to my opinion the overrated
mandalorian on disney plus this is their
best show
it's way more enticing and the writing
is just
spectacular every line means something
even the quick
jokes have some kind of reference to
something in the mcu
there's so much effort here and it moves
the plot on
way quicker than mandalorian and
actually isn't circular it's actually
something of mystery and keeping you
enticed of what's going to come
next week let me know what you thought
of this episode down below i'd love to
hear your thoughts i read every comment
and try to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of
wandavision
i also am reviewing the show serving at
the moment and your honor i also do a
bunch of celebrity interviews
so you don't want to miss any of those
and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time